in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
Ruth is with us hi Ruth how are you I'm
wonderful day how are you better than I
deserve where do you live
I live in Angleton Texas where is that
intact it's about 40 minutes south of
Houston okay all right very cool welcome
to Nashville thank you and you're here
to do it debt-free scream I am here to
be debt-free I love it
how much have you paid off I've paid off
$38,000 cool and how long did that take
you
I took me three years and eight months
in two distinct phases okay before I
found your program paid off $24,000 in
three years mm-hmm and after I found
your program and implemented it I've
paid off $14,000 in eight months
boom kicked it into overdrive that's
wonderful Wow so what was the big
difference what caused that that extra
gas on the fire well just I had started
my debt free journey as I said many
years before a funnier program and I've
tried to be in my life I lost my husband
unexpectedly
January of 2012 before all this started
this started okay and and I'm May of
2012 because we had lived a very normal
life I found myself in quite a bit of
financial trouble mmm in an ugly and fun
call from a creditor kind of got my
attention and when I got off the phone
with him finally we had a payment plan
worked out I was just devastated and I
took my dog for a walk you know and I
thought you know this is time I've
worked hard my whole life and I I'm not
gonna live like this anymore I'm going
to pay all this off and I'm never going
to go into debt again I don't care what
I'm gonna get out and so that began my
journey for about three years that's
just what I did I just hadn't heard
about you so I just was kind of sending
a little bit of extra to everybody
mm-hmm and then in January of 2015 I was
watching YouTube videos I'm not jr. I'm
sorry April of 2015 I was watching
YouTube videos about how to save money
and everybody kept talking about Dave
Ramsey Dave Ramsey you know is
Dave Ramsey these people are crazy but I
finally watched someone had uploaded a
lava vent of your baby steps and I was
hooked before you finished step two
because you're talking about the cheetah
chasing the the gazelle and you know
what he's gonna do he's going to get the
college student I thought oh my gosh
that's me because that's when my debt
journey that's when my debt started is
when I went to college and got my
teaching degree and so at that point I
just I wrote my first budget from May of
2015 so bad at it that I forgot to put
gas for the car in that budget that got
a lot better at it and in December 23rd
of 2015 exactly 44 months after that
phone call from Citibank that had
started the whole thing on May 23rd I
sent him their final payment and I was
done it was just so the Cheetos that I
did all that stuff it just gave you some
a track to run on and made you believe
you could do it and so that turned up
the heat and caused you to get out of
that even faster that and just really
was the missing key for me was always a
written budget in cash envelopes okay
I've always been very frugal I was a
single mom for a long time and I just I
named how to manage I knew how to
squeeze extra money out of my budget but
I didn't really have a plan for it
and I was amazed in May after telling
every dollar where to go and really
really just try my best to save every
one of them I could at how much I sure I
didn't realize how much money I really
did make until I started telling it
where to go for me and I've paid off one
of the smaller loans that first month I
paid off my pet student loan like two
months later and I thought I would have
another two years on there and that just
really that motivated me I got you going
I was I want this just about that point
the only thing I had left was the debt
consolidation loan gotcha
so through this three years and eight
months what was your average income
about fifty five thousand fifty five
thousand okay and how old are you I'm 49
years old so you were like 43 or 44 when
he passed away as poor as he passed away
the day before my 45
yeah okay so you're young you were a
young widow okay very cool good for you
and may I tell you and then just a few
months later man you get smacked with
this collector being sassy and that's
your wake-up call
cuz I was sent I was sending everybody a
payment I just couldn't make all the
minimum payments on my cell remote and
so the debt was even though I was
sending him four or five hundred dollars
a month which to me was a lot of money
that the debt was growing because they
changed the interest rate and of course
the light fees and penalties and all
that stuff so it was just that was just
how it like I said when when I got that
under control and really I think just
making up my mind I'm done with this I
worked too hard to have to have a phone
call when I'm still grieving and I'm
still mm-hmm you know right and you're
worried if I'm not telling you you know
I'm trying to make your payment but I
can't get it they're just nasty you know
it was and that's why I just think now
I'm grateful to God that I went through
that awful day because um debt free yeah
you are congratulations but at the time
you know very cool and so it's
interesting you were you were motivated
and then when you learned how to do the
budget the envelopes and started to see
the light a kind of that you could
actually you start to believe you'd
actually going to happen those three
things together we really put gas on the
fire and cause the thing to go into
overdrive that's what it sounds like
absolutely after I learned about your
program and I learned how to budget my
money and really make when I learned
that I really could live on money income
and I could live a good life and after
that I just I felt empowered up to that
point I had felt trapped you got to feel
like you got a s on your chest now I
mean you did it you did it you get it
right how does it feel you don't have
any payments it just it's amazing I mean
um have you ever been debt-free as an
adult
never I I was 22 as a single mom
I went back to college so I could
support my daughter and that's when I
went into debt I took on student loans
and I had ever since couldn't get out I
tried and tried but I just never could
get it all paid off and then of course I
met my husband and
he made a good salary and we you know I
felt like we were okay because all the
bills were paid on time and it just
seemed like in it I had always been kind
of raised to think you're always gonna
have a house payment you're always gonna
have a car payment no my dad did he
would always tell me you need get rid of
those credit cards
but you know the rest of the debt to me
I'm like there's nothing I want this
world badly enough to take on a debt on
I'm so happy of in that same three years
eight months I've also reduced my
mortgage by an additional twelve
thousand dollars it's going to be gone
soon and it will be gone what's the
balance on that how about 6300 you're
gonna kill it I love it
five four five more years you'll be done
yeah that's awesome well I'm so proud of
you Ruth congratulations you ought to be
proud of yourself
thank you good stuff you're a hero thank
you and I did I wanted to come I'm
actually a very shy person but I wanted
to come on your show because I wanted to
encourage there are single moms out
there and there are widows out there and
you're it's scary you think you're the
only one you know and you can't do it
and it's there's so much our culture
teaches us that you have to have two
incomes to have a good life and you do
not you can have a good life on one
income if you tell your money where to
go every month and you are conscious
about it and you budget faithfully and
you stick to that budget you can do it
you just encouraged a lot of people
thank you very very much thank you
absolutely incredible all right Ruth
from Houston Texas $38,000 paid off in
three years and eight months making
fifty five a year count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one I
am debt free
I didn't look too shy I like it I like
it I like it open phones this hour man
that's good stuff yes boom just like
that that's how it's done
I love it I love it I love it that is an
encouragement I don't want to hear your
whining you're sitting there making
90,000 bucks you just heard her story I
don't want to hear you can't do and I'm
not gonna listen to you you can do it
you'll be the hero of your story just
like Ruth is we're so proud of her
how good is that that's like that's good
stuff right there this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you